[Music]
what's your favorite doughnut and why my
favorite is the maple bar it's not so
sweet it's caramel they're soft it just
one of my favorite thing they all time
the donut shop business is Susan limbs
light her Orange County California donut
shop is just one of many that sprinkled
the US combined those stores and
producers make 10 billion donuts
annually every single donut I would took
a bite and I would throw away I took a
bite cuz I want to see the flavor of it
each and every one of them baked into
the back story of the shops glazed
dipped and twisted pastries is a
detailed and sometimes painful history
about Cambodian refugees see this donut
shop isn't just limp life it also gave
her family a new chance at life after
fleeing war-torn Cambodia in the 1970s
my mother's story makes me feel really
proud and honestly very empowered my
family's background is so rich and so
like straight out of a movie like these
things are don't happen to everyday
people limbs experience is only one of
many similar stories from Cambodian
refugees who settled in Southern
California and then open doughnut shops
as a way to survive and thrive in the
u.s. hey fam i me mayan and this sunday
we're actually doing a story that you
guys pitch to us we're looking at why
there are so many cambodian own donut
shops in southern california
[Music]
hi Amanda
Susan Lim says doughnuts have been very
sweet to her definitely American Dreams
to have a business it's American dream
just to do anything here I mean America
is definitely opened up doors to many
refugees like myself Lim bought this
donut shop from her parents after they
retired in 2004 she'd spent years
learning up-close about the family's
business because she started working in
it as a teenager but before her family
acquired more than a dozen donut shops
in Southern California they were
literally just trying to survive when
you talk about things like that it kind
of bring back memories
the suffering the starving limbs native
Cambodia was thrust into war when
Communists and anti-communist forces
battled for the nation's post-colonial
future according to Richard Kim the war
was actually an extension of the Vietnam
War which consumed Indochina all of it
rolled up into the Cold War which was an
ideological struggle about the spread of
communism the brutal war lasted for most
of the 1970s but the conditions that
ignited it had been years in the making
it's the result of decades of Konya rule
under the French and the power vacuum
that was left with the the ousting of
the king in 1970 power struggles emerged
over who had the right to rule Cambodia
Kim says the u.s. wasn't allowed to step
foot in Cambodia because it had been
declared neutral ground instead the
United States conducted an aerial
bombing campaign that failed and its
objective to destroy the supply line
that was the Ho Chi Minh Trail the
bombing killed Cambodians and devastated
the land this bombing devastated
Cambodia and Laos and this is probably
one reason also why the Khmer Rouge were
able to mobilize support from the
peasants in Cambodia to win the civil
war because many of them turned to more
radical ideology as a result of the
massive bombing Khmer Rouge would go on
to rule Cambodia with torturous tactics
and cruelty including what's become
known as the Cambodian killing fields
they were sites where people were
murdered
sometimes clubbed to death too
bullets and the key moment during the
war was when the Khmer Rouge conquered
the capital city opinon penh in 1975
they basically tried to exterminate the
educated class and Lim says her father
was one of the people who was targeted
here's how he managed to escape a deadly
bait my parents survived by pretending
to be to be dummy to be not educated to
be a farmers not educators not teachers
that's why they left them alone and not
not kill them
her parents used their home as a haven
for their children during the war the
Lim kids couldn't go to school life was
just about surviving the daily stressors
of war I still remember a little bit
about it being hungry being starving no
food no water I honestly don't know how
we survived during the war you have to
want to live in order to survive you
have to fight it's not a matter of
choice in 1979 the family decided to try
and escape the horrors surrounding them
Lim was only 12 years old like other
families the limbs paid a man to help
guide them to Thailand's border limbs
family walked for four days and three
nights
amid bombing remnants alongside hundreds
of others seeking reprieve and refuge
they really didn't take much I mean we
only brought maybe a few clothes to
change some food a little bit of money
there's not much to carry because
there's so many people trying to get out
of the city on foot no cars we basically
walk
miles and miles and miles her family
made it out to a refugee camp in
Thailand but many others wouldn't or
couldn't Lynne's infant brother is among
the wars casualties he essentially
starved to death Cambodian Civil War
would kill at least 1.5 million people
but the real toll could be up to 2
million and even the bit of freedom Lim
found in the refugee camp wasn't a break
from her suffering in some ways it was a
reminder of what she and her family had
lost and lacked they were watching this
lady bought candy for her children and
my mom looks at me and she couldn't
afford it and I just feel bad for my
brother's so limbs family spent a few
months in the Thai refugee camp before
her uncle Ted Nagao sponsored them to
come to the u.s. that's how she ended up
here in Southern California she says her
family was among the earliest Cambodian
refugees to the region Lim didn't speak
English and the transition was difficult
America is like where is America you
know didn't know where and when we got
to LAX it was so weird it's like you
know big tall people white people like
you know you never seen white people her
family arrived - in America deeply
divided about accepting refugees one
Harris poll taken in May 1975 found that
37% of Americans were in favor of
accepting the refugees 49 percent
opposed it and 14 percent weren't sure
even President Jimmy Carter essentially
refused entry to 40,000 Cambodian
refugees before later taking a more
humane approach to the conflicts victims
this was America's climate when Lin's
family moved in with her uncle and began
working at his donut shop my uncle is
he's the king of the donut his name is
Ted Nagoya Nagoya employ'd limbs parent
teaching them the tree in fact the very
first night Lin's family arrived in
California nagoya took her parents to
make donuts with him without him to help
that's recruiting us I don't know where
most Cambodian would be doing including
my family nagoya continued to sponsor
other Cambodian refugees hiring them
teaching them about the donut shop
business the many Cambodians who own
donut shops are Nagoya legacy as are the
pink boxes that have become synonymous
with Southern California stores limbs
daughter Amanda Lin Tang says her
great-uncle chose the pink boxes because
they were the least expensive
alternative I honestly could see myself
running this and I would hate for this
to not be a part of people's lives
anymore Tang is running parallel to her
grandparents path they work for Nagoya
for three to five years before
eventually saving enough money to buy
their own store that store became two
and then three and eventually more than
a dozen Susan Lim says her family's
story is an example of the American
dream
she hopes at least one of her five
children will one day join the business
but only after getting a college
education which she says she wasn't able
to do because she had to help her family
Susan limbs family is just one of more
than 2 million people who fled the
region between the 1970s in the 1990s
the United States took in more than 1
point 5 2 million of them some of the
refugees landed here in Long Beach
California and a place that today known
as Cambodia town it's filled with
businesses owned by Cambodians and now
some of the refugees who arrived as
children are who were born in refugee
camps are being repatriated to a nation
they've never really known the u.s. and
Cambodia is signed a Memorandum in 2002
saying an average of 35 people would be
deported annually and that was true
until 2016 that's when the Cambodian
government told the US Embassy and Pia
Phnom Penh that it would no longer
accept deportees until it had a chance
to review the issue the agreement allows
the u.s. to repatriate Cambodians who
committed a crime even if that crime is
a misdemeanor and even if they're
married to u.s. citizens by 2017 more
than 500 Cambodians have been deported
as part of the agreement and in the
first week of April 2018 the u.s.
supported the largest group of
Cambodians ever immigration officials
sent back more than 40 people to
Cambodia Lim says she doesn't personally
know anyone who's been affected by the
partitions and what she wants is the
legacy of Cambodian donut shop owners to
continue what I like most about working
here is meeting my customers my clients
talk to them wait on them make them
happy that's why I'm here I thank you so
much for watching don't forget to Like
share and subscribe and this story
proves we actually do read the comment
section so give us your story ideas
below and we'll look for you next Sunday